[Música]
hoy en el debate hacemos foco en el
Reino Unido este país lleva varios meses
inmerso en diferentes digamos pequeñas
crisis Todavía se siente el remezón que
dejó el brexit las consecuencias de la
pandemia de Kobe 19 la crisis económica
y recientemente se unió el cambio del
Primer Ministro la muerte de la reina
Isabel II la inflación el desploma de la
libra esterlina y la coyuntura en
materia energética toda esta presión ha
recaído sobre los hombros de la nueva
primera ministra listrass quien se
dirigió a la conferencia anual de su
partido en la ciudad de Birmingham este
fue tal vez el marco perfecto para
calmar un poco las aguas recuperar la
confianza después de ese paso en falso
en materia fiscal que pretendía bajar
los impuestos a los más adinerados
veamos
tras varias semanas de tempestad en las
que su plan de presupuesto provocó la
caída de la libra listo necesitaba un
estímulo su discurso en la conferencia
del partido conservador alentó a la
audiencia
[Aplausos]
tengo tres prioridades para nuestra
economía crecimiento crecimiento
crecimiento
el crecimiento fue prácticamente un
mantra en un discurso más breve de lo
habitual ofrecido por un líder Trust
admitió que los ahora archivados
recortes de impuestos para personas con
altos ingresos se habían convertido en
una distracción pero prometió una nueva
era de prosperidad para Reino Unido
libre de la supervisión de la Unión
Europea
estamos construyendo una economía que
aprovecha el máximo las enormes
oportunidades que ofrece el brexit a
finales de año todos los trámites
burocráticos con la Unión Europea
pasarán a la historia pero las cláusulas
propuestas podrían no ser tan populares
fuera del partido conservador como lo
demuestra una breve protesta de los
activistas de greenpeace quienes
acusaron a Trust de traicionar el
manifiesto electoral de su propio
partido Trust de los intentos de su
gobierno para hacer frente a la crisis
energética y dijo que la seguridad
energética era esencial para enfrentar
los nuevos desafíos geopolíticos
nos volvimos demasiado dependientes de
los regímenes autoritarios para obtener
bienes baratos y energía barata y no le
hicimos frente a Rusia lo
suficientemente pronto nos aseguraremos
de que esto nunca vuelva a suceder
La charla sobre el éxito futuro y los
impuestos bajos fue recibida
alentadoramente Por quienes asedian a la
primera ministra pero como los Stories
van detrás de los laboristas en las
encuestas por un amplio margen es
posible que el Distroller necesite algo
más que buenas palabras para ganarse a
su partido a largo plazo
Entonces nos quedan muchas preguntas
sobre la mesa Cuál es el rumbo que está
tomando el Reino Unido Hacia dónde va
este país europeo qué es lo que intenta
poner en marcha la primera ministra
Trust logrará el Reino Unido rápidamente
esa estabilidad que necesita después de
todos estos pequeños remesones que ha
venido Viviendo a lo largo de estos
últimos meses pues lo vamos a analizar
en esta edición del debate de France 24
para conversar sobre este tema saludamos
a Carmen Sepúlveda ella es phd cientista
política ya se encuentra en la ciudad de
Londres en la capital del Reino Unido y
desde la ciudad de Phoenix Arizona en
Estados Unidos se conecta el doctor
Daniel lacalle él es economista y
profesor en el business School también
les recuerdo que ustedes nuestros
televidentes hacen parte de este debate
pueden dejar todos sus comentarios y
preguntas a través de las redes sociales
estamos en Twitter en Facebook y en
instagram nos encuentran como arroba el
debate raya baja
f24@santilogo que es mi cuenta personal
nuestra etiqueta numeral el debate f24
no olviden también que todos los
contenidos de este programa también
están disponibles en podcast en
diferentes plataformas por supuesto
estamos en Apple podcast en Spotify
deezer y TuneIn
comienzo entonces dándole la bienvenida
a la doctora Carmen Sepúlveda bienvenida
Doctora gracias por estar con nosotros y
Punto de partida la primera pregunta
para conocer las posiciones este nuevo
escenario de crisis digo nuevo escenario
esto que vimos esta marcha atrás que dio
la primera ministra Trust en torno a su
plan fiscal
genera muchísima más incertidumbre de
cómo puede ser ese gobierno liderado por
listros que está pasando en este país
para entender Por qué no encuentra la
estabilidad un paso en falso de la
primera ministra genera más
incertidumbre
Santiago a ver crea más incertidumbre yo
creo que ya había incertidumbre en el
momento que Johnson deja el poder y que
llega el disfraz
se le elige básicamente en una
plataforma casi un chequen en blanco y
aparece después de estas dos semanas de
la muerte de la reina esta este anuncio
de este mini de este mini presupuesto y
en realidad yo creo que tomó un poco por
sorpresa mucha gente y lo más
sorprendente de todos es que tomó por
sorpresa su propio partido y a los
grupos a los grupos digamos más
moderados Quizás dentro de su propio
partido que se le habían dado vuelta y
hoy hoy día Eso era lo que estaba
tratando ella de controlar se habló de
un golpe por parte de su gente de suelo
abrir desde que se le Estaba tratando de
hacer un golpe al criticarle el manejo
de la economía después de los anuncios
de cuasi cuartel y bueno Tuvimos una
crisis o sea el banco de Inglaterra tuvo
que intervenir para poder controlar se
desplomarán y los fondos de pensiones ni
ni la libra mayormente
Sí o sea la verdad es que hasta cierto
punto sí tomó por sorpresa a todo el
mundo
y hago la misma pregunta al doctor
Daniel la calle también Bienvenido al
programa doctor Daniel este escenario de
crisis de incertidumbre qué es lo que
está pasando en el Reino Unido que no
alcanza la estabilidad
Bueno yo creo que lo que está ocurriendo
en el Reino Unido es de una combinación
de distintos elementos no el primero que
no debemos olvidar es que el monetario
este llamado desplome de la libra no es
un problema de la libra es un problema
de todas las monedas contra el dólar
para que nos hagamos una idea el yen
japonés ha caído más que la libra contra
el dólar la corona sueca la corona
Noruega la danesa el euro etcétera
etcétera no y el Banco Central de Japón
y el Banco Central del china también han
tenido que intervenir durante toda la
semana y de hecho el de Japón continúa
interviniendo lo primero que tenemos que
desligar es la caída de la libra porque
es fácil Buscar una causalidad que no
tiene que no tiene este caso particular
Pero es verdad que el gran problema en
el Reino Unido es que
el gobierno conservador la plataforma
conservadora que ganó con el
en el ministro por Johnson se presentó
con un programa para
llevar a cabo ese brexit que se había
anunciado y que desde el punto de vista
de la gran mayoría de las personas que
han votado a favor de esa opción
particularmente no era yo
particularmente defensor del brexit para
nada pues se encuentran con que no se ha
cumplido lo que buscaban no se había
vendido una idea de brexit que era una
especie de panacea y lo que ha ocurrido
ahora es que se presenta un plan
económico un plan económico que por otro
lado es más de lo mismo de lo que
llevamos viviendo el Reino Unido durante
mucho tiempo con distintos gobiernos es
decir gastar mucho más y en algunos
casos bajar un poco los impuestos en
otros subir un poco subirlos un poco
pero el problema del déficit estructural
del Reino Unido y del aumento constante
de gasto muy por encima de los ingresos
en cualquier circunstancia se crezca o
no se
le hago esta pregunta a los dos tal vez
para entender este contexto estamos
viendo una ola tardía digamoslo así me
gustaría llamarlo así puede ser el
término de la repercusiones que está
dejando el brexit en el Reino Unido
siempre se pensó que la salida del Reino
Unido de la Unión Europea iba a tener un
efecto inmediato efectivamente así fue
hubo medidas que fueron
de efecto inmediato y se sintieron tanto
de este lado del Atlántico como para los
británicos pero estamos ante efectos
tardíos de de esta decisión que tomó el
gobierno británico doctora Carmen
En parte sí yo creo que sí O sea como
dices tú si hubieron efectos inmediatos
un poco desordenes administrativos
Yo creo que el movimiento sobre todo de
la gente fue algo que golpeó muy fuerte
a los ingleses que yo creo no habían
dimensionado lo que significaba no poder
tener libre de movimiento pero los
efectos ya más estructurales dentro de
la economía inglesa persé junto al tema
del mercado del trabajo que de repente
se encuentra con que no hay bastante
fuerza laboral
digamos en puestos de trabajo quizás no
tan especializados porque se fueron
muchas muchos muchos ciudadanos europeos
de vuelta a sus países
ahora relanza después de que habían
tenido un discurso absolutamente
contradictorio antimigración con que
quieren más inmigración pero al mismo
tiempo no quieren más refugiados y se
los quiere mandar a Ruanda entonces
todas estas cosas sí son un poco
resultado de brexit que no sé que yo
creo que no se dimensionó y bueno se
mintió digamos lo como es se mintió
abiertamente sobre los efectos
económicos que iba a tener o los
beneficios económicos que esto iba a
tener incluyendo el dinero que se iba a
poder reinvertir dentro de por ejemplo
el Sistema Nacional de salud que es una
deuda que ellos dijeron Bueno iba a ser
de 350 millones de pan al sistema se le
iba a agregar para poder mantenerlo y no
fue así entonces sí Ahora la el
endeudamiento lo que hablamos sí ha sido
una constante pero también llevamos 10
años 12 incluso de austeridad austeridad
severa la crisis no es de ahora lo que
ellos están manejando es lo que yo mismo
construyeron lo que pasa es que no se
están haciendo cargo yo creo dentro del
gobierno de sus propias medidas Sí tal
vez están escapoteando la crisis
económica pero no están dándole solución
a esa crisis y el problema de fondo tal
vez puede ser lo que decía el doctor
se gasta mucho y se recauda muy poco y
se pone este círculo vicioso No termina
doctor Daniel su opinión sobre este tema
del brexit sobre si estamos viendo
secuelas de esta decisión y también
porque el escenario creo que no le ha
jugado al Reino Unido a favor seamos
justos también ahí pues la pandemia
claramente afectó a todos los países es
esperado acuerdo con comercial con
Estados Unidos que iban a firmar con
Donald Trump nunca llegó que era el gran
Aliado que iba a llegar a a suplir esos
mercados que dejaban de la Unión Europea
y pues la economía en general a nivel
mundial no va bien Esto tampoco pues
claramente le juega a favor al Reino
Unido
efectivamente yo creo que hay que
ponerlo en el contexto del mundo
por supuesto que el brexit prometía o
los defensores de
brexitían una serie de cosas
muy a largo plazo y por supuesto Pues
que pueden ser más que cuestionables no
pero el gran problema que se encuentra
el Reino Unido es que
no es tanto un problema sobre lo que
está ocurriendo en todo el mundo que es
completamente cierto es que es verdad
que ha habido un elemento de riesgo muy
importante en las economías mundiales
ese elemento de riesgo y de crisis se ha
dado también en el Reino Unido pero es
verdad que si el Reino Unido tiene que
compararse pues con el con la eurozona
pues tanto tanto en desempleo como en
crecimiento en la época de crecimiento
como en caída en la época de caída que
ha sido menor y sobre todo lo más
importante Al fin y al cabo que es el
empleo Pues la verdad es que bueno pues
se puede poner en contexto que la
economía británica no va ni mejor ni
peor por el brexit Yo creo que es que lo
que ha mostrado es toda esta
polarización que Se generó con el brexit
ha sido uno que la eurozona no va mejor
sin el Reino Unido dos que el Reino
Unido tampoco va ni mejor ni peor fuera
de la Unión Europea que había toda una
serie de engranajes diferentes Entonces
yo creo que aquí esto es un problema de
largo plazo Porque todos los que vivimos
en el Reino Unido llevo 25 años y
probablemente la doctora también muchos
años sabemos que la la posición de apoyo
a la Unión Europea no es elevada es
entre la población en general y que por
lo tanto el Reino Unido va a tener que
buscar su propio camino hablábamos antes
de austeridad hombre un país que gasta
un 46% de su producto interior bruto
todos los años yo no lo llamaría desde
luego austeridad Yo creo que el gran
problema Reino Unido es lo contrario Es
que llevamos con políticas de
en las que siempre se soluciona todo
aumentando el gasto y sobre todo
consolidándolo con el nivel del previo
porque no es que se diga vamos a
priorizar el chef la sanidad o vamos a
priorizar otra cosa No aquí siempre se
consolida y se añade no Y claro el Reino
Unido es una economía muy dinámica y
necesita y necesita Por lo tanto tener
unas priorizaciones que no se están
llevando a cabo porque se han diluido
completamente Bueno pues las posiciones
tanto por el lado socialdemócrata o
laborista como lo quieran llamar y el
lado conservador como lo quieran Llamar
Hay un problema claramente de
pues fiscal no
doctora Sepúlveda Quiero que analicemos
en detalle la figura de la primera
ministra listros lo que uno puede ver
desde fuera de las fronteras británicas
y fuera de Europa es que tal vez le ha
costado un poco encontrar su rumbo en
términos políticos
comunicar exactamente qué es lo que
quiere hacer en esta área económica
porque ha dicho que quiere hacer unos
cambios unas reformas y que esto es un
plan a largo plazo pero tampoco da
muchos detalles de qué es lo que quiere
hacer y cómo lo va a hacer tal vez está
fallando la comunicación detrás con el
resto del gobierno y con los ciudadanos
y también porque le tocó una coyuntura
muy difícil solamente dos días después
de haber asumido el cargo y es que se
muere la Reina Isabel que es tal vez la
noticia de la década a nivel mundial y
le toca hacer frente a esta situación
que también Pues desubica un poco a la
sociedad británica
Fíjate que no pienso que le esté
fallando la comunicación es lo más
mínimo creo que hay un gran nivel de
improvisación es lo que están haciendo
hay también un gran nivel de ideología
de una de una incapacidad a salir de lo
que ellos piensan no creen debe ser
frente a la realidad y a lo que la gente
está esperando de ellos el anuncio de
recortes de impuestos hacia la hacia las
capas más
altas de la sociedad en términos de
ingreso cayó muy mal en una época donde
hay una crisis económica grande que se
viene una crisis energética y si bien lo
que decía el profesor antes y puede ser
cierto Hasta cierto punto de que hay un
gasto enorme en Inglaterra también yo
creo que sí llevamos 10 12 años de
austeridad yo creo que sí se vienen
recortando sobre todos los presupuestos
en gasto social de modo bastante fuerte
a la ncharse privatizar por dentro y eso
ha llevado a que la gente sufre de
digamos de problemas en su cotidiano
bastante importante las escuelas están
faltando de recursos para enfrentar la
crisis energética o sea en escuelas
públicas está hablando de que no van a
poder pagar las cuentas del para
calentar en la escuela o si es que
contratan un profesor Por ende no se
contrata al profesor para poder cubrirse
eso soy yo digamos en los presupuestos
se está cargando digamos la el costo de
intervención del banco de Inglaterra a
los 68 billones
de libras se van a cargar a la gente más
pobre del país que vive de University
no de las ayudas sociales directas para
mantenerse para sobrevivir es a ellos
que se les está traspasando el costo a
final de cuentas de un mal manejo de la
comunicación y de la toma de decisiones
de políticas económicas yo creo que no
para nada no no están cometiendo redes
de comunicación saben perfectamente lo
que están haciendo son un grupo de gente
dentro del partido Tori que viene con
una ideología muy clara o sea hoy día lo
dijo graves crecimiento crecimiento
crecimiento emulando un poquito así como
tu nivel le dio énfasis a la educación
educación educación Ellos dicen que no
que todo esto es crecimiento es una
agenda neoliberal que vuelve siempre que
veníamos de vuelta de una crítica a la
ley del chorreo o sea perdón a la
economía del chorreo y el efecto del
chorreo que no No termina dando
resultados también iba a reducir
iniquidades ni rebajar la pobreza que
por lo demás o sea en Inglaterra se ha
disparado tenemos 3.9 millones de niños
viviendo labores en este momento doctora
ya la doy la palabra doctor la calle
Entonces en ese orden de ideas y
entonces entendiendo que para usted la
comunicación está funcionando fue
estratégico mandar Este plan de
fiscal que era un pequeño plan fiscal
justo en medio de la coyuntura en la que
estaban en este momento después del de
la reina está transición en la monarquía
y también el marco de la guerra en
Ucrania que genera pues nerviosismo e
incertidumbre en todo el continente
europeo era una coyuntura que les
funcionaba a favor y tal vez no les
funcionó
yo no no creo que es que no se le
funcionara la coyuntura Yo creo que es
que el problema del partido conservador
en el Reino Unido desde la llegada de
Boris Johnson es que intenta ser dos
cosas a la vez intenta soplar y sorber
no por un lado tiene una agenda de gasto
sin precedentes por otro lado el gasto
social en los últimos 20 años no ha
hecho más que incrementarse por encima
del producto interior bruto nominal y
eso ya de entrada muestra que no es un
problema de falta de gasto su problema
un problema en el Reino Unido Hay un
problema clarísimo de ineficiencia en el
gasto es uno de los países con mayor
ineficiencia en el gasto que ya se
empezó con con el Gobierno laborista no
yo creo que el problema aquí es mucho
más sencillo es que
en todas las soluciones vengan por el
lado de los laboristas venga por el lado
de los conservadores son gastar mucho
más y gastar mucho más Cómo imprimiendo
moneda de hecho la política que prometía
Jeremy que ya no está era una masiva
emisión de moneda y por lo tanto
muchísimo más inflación entonces como
bien decía la doctora claro
los más pobres porque como siempre con
la inflación si tú todas las medidas que
se toman son inflacionistas mucho más
gastos mucho más déficit y monetizar ese
déficit vamos no existe ningún país del
mundo desde Argentina a Venezuela desde
Turquía a Reino Unido con las
diferencias de cada uno en las que no lo
paguen como no puede ser de otra manera
la gente a la que le está pagando en
unas monedas que cada vez valen menos
Pero eso no es un problema solamente de
Reino Unido es un problema de una
percepción de global de que los
desequilibrios de una economía Fiscales
se pueden solventar que es una falacia
histórica se pueden solventar con mágica
con ideas mágicas monetarias sí doctor
la calle continuó con usted para cerrar
este tema económico yo no soy economista
pero lo que
entendí haciendo la investigación para
este programa es que otro escenario que
hay allí es que tienen un grave problema
de esta inflación es decir que hay una
combinación de muy bajo crecimiento
económico pero también hay una rápida
subida de los precios que es lo que
estamos viendo con la alta inflación que
se está presentando lo que usted dice
una de las medidas que han propuesto es
imprimir dinero tratando de dinamizar la
economía pero son medidas que juegan en
contra de otros problemas Entonces se
ataca la inflación para el no no mejora
o se ataca y se toman medidas para
crecer Pero entonces la inflación no
disminuye este callejón sin salida que
como usted lo dice no es solamente del
Reino Unido varios países están en esta
situación Cómo se puede empezar a salir
de allí
vamos a ver es muy difícil y la razón es
la siguiente me da Exactamente igual el
color de las políticas que se pongan
cuando lo que se está poniendo encima de
la mesa constantemente en todo en muchos
países desarrollados y y en vías de
desarrollo constantemente es una
política en la que se hace creer a la
gente que 2 + 2 suman 22 el resultado
siempre es esta inflación siempre y
siempre nos intentan decir que esta vez
va a ser diferente entonces el problema
del Reino Unido es claramente el mismo
problema que el de la eurozona que hizo
Exactamente lo mismo por otro lado
masivamente aumentar la cantidad de
dinero en circulación para entre
comillas crecer y pagar muchos más
cheques y muchos más en servicios
sociales etcétera y no deja de ser
exactamente lo mismo de siempre Esto no
es ninguna novedad y además por otro
lado los que hemos vivido en el Reino
Unido durante décadas es que
la época en los años 70 en los que se
hacía Exactamente lo mismo con gobiernos
laboristas Y algún conservador me da
Exactamente igual Sí aquí se está
intentando contar la idea en todo en
todo el mundo que los problemas Fiscales
se solucionan con medidas monetarias y
no solamente no ocurre sino que además
se empobrece muchísimos más muchísimo
más a aquellos que fingen proteger ese
es el problema del populismo de
izquierda o de derecha me da igual
porque los colores son irrelevantes Aquí
está implementando
doctora sepúlverá su opinión sobre esto
y le extiendo un poco la pregunta a
usted que está en el Reino Unido usted
está en el día a día de esta situación
que comentan los británicos que comentan
los ingleses sobre esta situación hay un
descontento hay incertidumbre además que
ha habido muchos remesones ya lo decía
yo solamente el remezón de la muerte de
la reina ya le generó una pérdida de
rumbo a muchas personas muy
promonárquicos y el tema económico Pues
los afecta
precisamente por el bien de sus familias
es todo lo que acabas de decir
yo mismo La pregunta
es incertidumbre es dudas sobre lo que
se viene es un poco lo que acaba de
explicar el profesor sobre qué se hace
cuando uno escucha opiniones tan
diferentes sobre cómo
atacar un problema como la inflación que
sí hay muchos factores que no dependen
del Reino Unido sino que es a nivel
global también
Y sí en la muerte de la reina causó un
remezón yo creo a la estabilidad como
también a los sentimientos de unidad del
Reino Unido porque no es estamos
viviendo muchas cosas son muchas capas
las que estamos viviendo no lo económico
lo social en ciertos aspectos pero
también está ese Reino Unido no esa
relación con gales esa relación con
Irlanda esa relación con Escocia en la
salida de la Unión Europea Cuál cuál A
qué se va a aparecer este nuevo Reino
Unido Qué será de este Reino Unido que
se conocía hasta ahora pero que en el
fondo un poco muere con la reina Yo creo
que hay algo ahí muy simbólico y que
venga detrás una crisis económica tan
fuerte
con la preocupación no sé de cómo van a
pagar sus hipotecas la gente está
preocupada de cómo van a pagar sus
hipotecas como Cómo van a poder
manejar su presupuesto mensual o de aquí
a un año
sí causa mucho temor yo creo y eso
afecta a los mercados Y eso explica
también por qué una gran parte del
partido del ISR se da vuelta contra ella
y bueno Y también está digamoslo
abiertamente hoy hoy día lo que se vio
en la conferencia cuando ya habló fue el
malestar de decir con este tipo de
anuncios y con esta este moda
antagonizar de modo ideológico con la
realidad que la gente está viviendo van
a perder las próximas elecciones les da
un margen muy pequeño de ganar las
próximas elecciones la proyección es que
si la elección fuera hoy día perderían
alrededor de 190 a 200 Cómo se llama
miembros del parlamento lo que le daría
una mayoría pero por una golpiza por
golpiza a leiber y sería un efecto un
poco como la ola que hubo el 97 Entonces
es todo eso lo que está pasando al mismo
tiempo y yo creo que sí en el Reino
Unido están los vientos están dando
vueltas muy rápido Sí hay vientos
huracanados digámoslo así allá en el
Reino Unido usted menciona las capas de
estas diferentes crisis doctoras
Sepúlveda yo me subo una capa más y
habló precisamente de la cohesión del
Reino Unido usted menciona bueno gales
Irlanda del Norte Escocia Escocia tiene
serias intenciones de realizar este
referendo para retirarse del Reino Unido
y aspira a ser un país un poco más
inmerso en la Unión Europea y también
hay unos Vientos de mucho cambio en
algunos de los terri de ultramar y los
países que pertenecen a la comunidad a
la mancomunidad también a nivel político
como es la percepción ahí como Cómo se
está sintiendo estos revolcones que está
generando la primera ministra en estas
capas de del Reino Unido
yo creo que hoy día fue muy simbólico
que ella diera una especie de una
pequeña una pequeña frase y atacando un
poco la reacción de no cierto de Escocia
culpandolos de parte de los problemas y
la inmediata respuesta detrás de Nicolás
sergin diciéndole
pongamos las cosas en su lugar
la responsabilidad de ustedes nosotros
aquí no tenemos nada que ver y es Santa
agonía que uno siente en el cotidiano es
muy fuerte y realmente está causando
mucha atención yo creo que los escoceses
y ellos tienen bastante claros de que
van van a querer ese referéndum de
Independencia y al Distroller se le
puede complicar aún más
su posición si es que no logra manejar
eso y mantener al Reino Unido sí doctor
la calle su opinión sobre este tema Cómo
mantener esa cohesión del Reino Unido y
la largo La pregunta es momento que
Londres y Bruselas conversen ya en
buenos términos y se pongan firmes con
las cartas sobre la mesa de Cómo mejorar
esa relación que va pero pero no marcha
fluidamente
Sí yo empezaría por esa última parte no
esa política que ante el brexit se ha
creado de Vegeta de
empobrecer al vecino de que la Unión
Europea Quería dar el ejemplo de que
Inglaterra de que el Reino Unido iba a
ir muy mal y al revés no el Reino Unido
de que el resto de la eurozona la Unión
Europea iba a ir muy mal ninguna de las
dos cosas tiene ningún sentido y tienen
que hablar y bueno eso es perfectamente
normal la cohesión del Reino Unido
siempre es un problema y siempre ha sido
un problema digamos de medio y largo
plazo en el que hay una serie de
catalizadores a corto plazo ahora mismo
estamos hablando de ese referéndum no y
no podemos olvidar en cualquier caso que
el referéndum de independencia de
Escocia lo perdió lo perdió el
independentismo y y que hubo en menos de
24 horas ya estaban pidiendo otro
referéndum porque a la independentismo
le da igual el resultado del referéndum
hasta que salga
pero fuera de todo eso Yo creo que el
Reino Unido
ese ese aunque sea un catalizador
digamos
mediático más que más que Real Es verdad
que hay un cambio a medida que está
generando desde hace muchos años Que es
esa esa polarización Y esa división de
un Reino Unido en el que siempre ha
habido una Unión frágil y una Unión muy
complicada verdad pero yo creo que
no es un tema de
su gobierno porque
la alternativa laborista no es no
estamos hablando de pasar a Tony Blair y
Golden Brown para nada en en el Reino
Unido lo que estamos hablando es que
todos estos errores económicos y
monetarios lo que estamos acusando con
toda la razón Ah el gobierno de Boris
Johnson
multiplicar sí gana un gobierno
laborista por lo lo que más pena me da
como Ciudadano que ha vivido y que vive
muchos años de la décadas en el Reino
Unido es que cualquiera de las
alternativas que se presentan en el
Reino Unido va a empobrecer masivamente
a la población porque todas están
basadas en Dos más Dos suman 22 que
claramente es una fórmula que ya está
comprobado que no funciona
hay un asunto importante de temas
internos allá en el Reino Unido lo
anunciaba el ministro Irlandés de
asuntos exteriores Simon coventy que
hablaba que el Reino Unido y la Unión
Europea han acordado entablar una
conversación para resolver estos
problemas del protocolo de Irlanda del
Norte también un tema que el gobierno de
Boris Johnson trató de quitarse de
encima lo más rápido posible y que
muestra de pronto ese entendimiento que
está empezando a darse entre Londres y
Bruselas
este diálogo puede generar
puede llegar a buen Puerto como lo ve
usted doctora Sepúlveda sobre el
resultado de lo que puede esto empezar a
generar y también un poco más de
tranquilidad al interior del Reino Unido
o usted cómo lo ve
yo creo que yo creo que hay una
necesidad por parte del Reino Unido de
mejorar la relación con Europa esto En
parte por el conflicto que se dio en
Ucrania no a la guerra
no Inglaterra se dio cuenta al salir o
sea con el brexit de que lo que ellos
soñaban en el rol que ellos iban a
ocupar a nivel internacional no era lo
que habían prometido ni lo que yo
soñaban estamos hablando al grupo del
brexit y que su vecino más cercano es
Europa que la fuerza quizás para ellos
para posicionarse no era Estados Unidos
Estados Unidos hasta cierto punto les ha
dado vuelto un poquito a la espalda y
les ha dicho o sea tratados de comercio
especiales con ustedes etcétera
no va a haber Por ende con quién nos
queda poder negociar y acercarnos sobre
todo ahora que hay un conflicto en el
cual también se tiene bien coordinar un
poco coordinar un poquito mejor las
respuestas frente a lo que pasa con
Putin y Rusia Yo creo que el protocolo
de Landa tiene que avanzar o sea todo
eso tiene que avanzar no y no hay otra
no hay otro no hay otro no hay otro modo
Porque además sería abrir un frente de
conflicto innecesario cuando ya tiene la
casa Ardiendo
claro doctor la calle su opinión sobre
este tema del protocolo de Irlanda esta
necesidad de estabilizarse adentro como
dice la doctora porque la casa ya está
en llamas
si ese es una es un civil
pues probable Yo creo que es importante
es importante llegar a un acuerdo Ahora
yo no veo la posibilidad de llegar a un
acuerdo porque la posición de ambas
partes es bastante numantina y y no es y
no es sencilla Pero bueno hay que
sentarse y buscar y Buscar opciones de
diálogo pero yo no veo la posibilidad yo
creo que aquí hay un problema también de
percepción en la Unión Europea yo estaba
hace poco en Bruselas hay una idea que
es francamente equivocada que es la idea
de pensar que si se espera a que haya
unas nuevas elecciones el próximo
gobierno va a revertir el brexit y el
Reino Unido vuelve a la Unión Europea y
vuelve al redil digamos con
con el rabo de las piernas bueno Y eso
no va a ocurrir Y eso no
nos estamos dando cuenta muchas veces en
el análisis sobre todo viviendas de la
Unión Europea es que el Reino Unido
en Inglaterra
ese barco ya ha salido ese barco ya ha
salido y por lo tanto a partir de ahí
tienen que buscar una un acuerdo yo los
veo muy difícil
el panorama que usted describe doctor la
paz en la calle llegamos al bloque final
llegamos a las conclusiones para cerrar
todo este análisis de la situación en el
Reino Unido y lo que está viviendo la
primera ministra listros qué sigue para
las próximas semanas los próximos meses
de lo que puede venir en términos
económicos y políticos para el Reino
Unido siempre lo digo acá no tenemos la
bola de cristal para saber el futuro
pero desde su perspectiva y desde su
análisis Qué puede estar enfrentando el
Reino Unido en los próximos días
comienzo con usted doctora Sepúlveda
a ver
yo estoy pensando que
el laurismo va a ser todo lo posible
para dejar que listo siga pisando los
palitos
y caiga ella misma en aún más errores y
va a haber una gran presión por parte de
los empis dentro del partido Tori
para tratar de revertir alguna de estas
situaciones porque son graves para la
reelección o sea pongámoslo así la
última elección que ganaron los Stories
hizo un hoyito lo que se llama en el Red
Ball en el muro rojo del norte de
Inglaterra en el cual ellos obtuvieron
digamos
Perdón
parlamentarios que no habrían tenido y
eso les permitió ganar digamos esas
elecciones ahora
ese ese muro se está volviendo rojo
nuevamente y se está llenando de rojo
debido y exclusivamente a lo que ha
pasado en las últimas dos semanas o sea
hubo un salto de 38 puntos
en las encuestas que anuncie que el
laborismo tiene grandes probabilidades
de arrasar yo creo que no podemos hacer
como que esto no está pasando está
pasando entonces lo que ellos va a tener
que hacer es tener grandes negociaciones
con su gente dentro sí que quiere
mantener el control
y
manejar mejor
los anuncios económicos que va a lanzar
doctor la calle rápidamente su
conclusión
yo creo que las próximas semanas
próximos meses el Reino Unido se va a
enfrentar a una
a una pequeña recuperación de los
últimos datos económicos que le puede
servir como apoyo y sobre todo por
comparación con respecto a la eurozona
a litros en cualquier caso Yo creo que
da igual porque
las encuestas en el Reino Unido luego no
se cumple Yo recuerdo pues recuerdo unas
encuestas antes de la mayoría absoluta
claro
también daban una mayoría al laborismo
verdad Igual yo creo que el gran factor
que tiene que al que se tiene que
enfrentar los próximos meses va a ser el
siguiente y es el que el hecho de que la
libra y el euro y el yen no tienen ahora
mismo el soporte que tenían antes y por
lo tanto continuar con una política
monetaria
se me acaba el tiempo tengo que
informativo les agradezco mucho por
haber hecho este análisis para la
audiencia de France 24 ustedes pueden
seguir en sintonía de toda la
programación de France 24 siga con
nosotros
[Música]